but here we're going to use a shortcut
that's learned in calculus called the
power rule and the way this works is you
take this exponent and you bring it down
in front of the variable here x and you
subtract one then from the exponent so a
simple example would be like say you had
uh 7 x to the 5th you would bring that
five down 5 * 7 is 35 and then You'
subtract one from the exponent so that'd
be four so that's your derivative and
remember what is the derivative the
derivative is really A four formula for
finding the slope of the tangent line
and what we're going to do is we're
going to use the x coordinate to plug in
for X to then find the slope at that
point